[Musica]
buongiorno e benvenuti
io inizio il mio spiccioli facendo una
domanda sicuramente conoscerete chi è il
personaggio sullo schermo si tratta di
batman batman batman è un supereroe e ha
una caratteristica che lo distingue
dagli illustri colleghi almeno da alcuni
di loro non ha superpoteri batman non
volano una raggi laser che escono dagli
occhi non sposta gli oggetti con la
forza del pensiero semplicemente a dei
gadget iper tecnologici e indossa una
maschera un costume e combatte i cattivi
per le strade di gotham city
quando torna sulla nella bat caverna
toglie la maschera il costume chi torna
ad essere torna ad essere bruce wayne e
bruce wayne
chiaramente non può essere considerato
l'uomo medio perché un multimilionario
ma bruce wayne è molto interessante come
personaggio perché al suo interno
coesistono soprattutto per come l'ha
reso chris nolan non so se avete visto
l'ultima trilogia lo ha reso molto umano
con una spiccata umanità con un accento
molto forte sui punti deboli punti di
forza sulle sue paure sui tram traumi
lato anaffettivo ma anche il coraggio e
l'intraprendenza dal tour e
dell'altruismo quindi è molto
affascinante il lato bruce wayne e e
quello che aggancia poi lo spettatore a
seguire a seguire un film pensate quanto
noiosi sono colpi di me fatti solo di
combattimenti ed effetti speciali a me
non piacciono e credo a una buona parte
di gente che ama il cinema non piace e
perché dico questo perché io a modo mio
ho a che fare con dei super eroi come
batman i miei supereroi sono i miei
atleti i campioni della scherma
loro hanno in comune compatto ma neanche
un costume una maschera solo che quando
noi indossano non vanno a combattere i
cattivi per le strade di gotham city ma
cercano di superare gli avversari e
molto spesso vi riescono la scherma lo
ricordiamo lo sport più medagliato
d'italia e per me sono una leva di
promozione molto importante una leva di
marketing
mentale da questo punto di vista e
quindi quando loro fanno suonare l'inno
di momento in ogni parte del mondo sono
i super eroi italiani quando però si
tolgono la maschera il costume tornano
ad essere dei ragazzi come noi
normalissimi con i loro sogni le loro
ambizioni le loro paure frustrazioni in
video e tutto quello che di interessante
c'è all'interno dell'animo umano ed è
quello che soprattutto per uno sport
come quello di cui mi occupo io che
molto difficile da un punto di vista
della comprensione delle regole aiuta a
appassionarsi e delle storie
solo che il problema è che prima
dell'avvento dell'era dei social media
io non avevo un contenitore dove poter
raccontare quotidianamente le loro
storie vi era soltanto una parte della
storia quella dei le scene d'azione
quindi l'aspetto sportivo ma non c'era
un contenitore e non c'era un budget per
potere soprattutto se parliamo di media
tradizionali per poter contenere queste
storie e raccontarle al grande pubblico
grazie all'era dei social media quindi
si è aperta un'enorme opportunità ve lo
dico subito opportunità è la parola
chiave di questo speech e la parola il
minimo comune denominatore di ogni slide
che opportunità in questo caso nel mio
ambito professionale ma opportunità che
oggi i social media hanno portato nelle
nostre vite
impostando dei nuovi modelli i social
media sono degli strumenti non sto qui a
celebrarli possono essere usati bene
possono essere usati male se usati bene
dal mio punto di vista in primis sono
forieri di opportunità opportunità di
essere connessi e quindi parliamo di
magro opportunità quelle che riguardano
tutti essere connessi con il mondo
intero altro che sei gradi di
separazione massimo in due passaggi
arriviamo a chi vogliamo
nascono nuovi audience pensiamo agli
under 20 quelli che magari stanno nella
stessa stanza e non parlano guardandosi
negli occhi ma chattano giusto o
sbagliato che sia è un nuovo linguaggio
nuovo modo di comportarsi e se si vuole
dialogare con questo nuovo audience e
avere l'opportunità di farlo bisogna
presidiare questi territori abbiamo gli
over 60 che all'inizio hanno combattuto
strenuamente l'avvento di questa nuova
era ma ne sono stati assorbiti in toto e
si sono convertiti anche perché in una
società sempre più globale e forse
l'unico modo per essere partecipi delle
vite dei figli dei nipoti che vivono
dall'altra parte d'italia o del mondo
abbiamo il papa che twitter latina
abbiamo il primo presidente di colore
degli stati uniti che vince due volte le
elezioni proprio grazie ai social media
arrivando dritto al cuore della gente
quindi senza filtri imposti da media
tradizionali
abbiamo anche dei processi velocissimi
ad esempio pensiamo la parola selphy la
parola selphy esplosa quando quando c'è
stato quel selphy durante la notte degli
oscar del 2014 uno dei contenuti più
virali del web
ellen degeneres da conduttrice fece quel
selphy con le star hollywoodiane bene la
parola selphy velocemente in pochi
giorni entrò all'interno del nostro
vocabolario ma non solo la parola ma
anche il gesto di farsi un self quindi
emulazione comportamentale a tutti gli
effetti
viviamo due vite parallele ricordate in
matrix se avete capito che mi piace il
cinema e pillola rossa pillola blu
morfeo soffriva anni ho la possibilità
di stare dentro matrix o di uscire fuori
e vedere com'era la vita reale noi
questo lo facciamo ogni volta ogni
giorno più volte al giorno non è una
scelta senza ritorno basta un log in e
una password entriamo e usciamo molto
spesso non parliamo di luna che esclude
l'altra ma di una che completa l'altra e
molto spesso a vita online offre alla
vita offline delle opportunità molto
interessanti
oggi parliamo di personal branding le
persone dialogano sul web o sui social
soprattutto come se fossero dei brand a
tutti gli effetti ma ciò che è molto
interessante è che i brand da quando
esistono i social dialogano come persone
ci fate caso lo fanno gli auguri di
compleanno
i pesci d'aprile a volte fanno anche
delle brutte figure il web è pieno di
epic games e i mercati sono diventati
conversazione non c'è più il big brand
che bombarda di messaggi il consumer che
passivamente li subisce non può
replicare
adesso è tutto conversazione confronto e
questa è una delle cose più interessanti
uno dei processi più interessanti e
amplificazione l'opportunità di
amplificare ogni messaggio io non
soltanto immagino appunto scrivere un
posto come salire su un palco come
questo virtuale ovviamente
e parlare a una piazza del fatta da ics
persone ma dell'amplificazione mi piace
un concetto insito cioè quello del mixer
in ogni strategia soprattutto se
parliamo di marketing e comunicazione
cosa si fa si alza il volume i punti di
forza lo si diminuisce ai punti di
debolezza in questo i social innescano
un processo potentissimo i social sono
democrazia
una ventata democratica non voglio
scomodare tutti gli episodi in cui
regimi dittatoriali sono stati
rovesciati ma oggi ognuno di noi
potenzialmente può dire la propria parte
dallo stesso punto degli altri perché
potenzialmente perché la democrazia è
solo potenziale
se non vi è un altro concetto
fondamentale che è quello di
meritocrazia per meritocrazia significa
avere la consapevolezza che questi
strumenti non sono una perdita di tempo
non vengono utilizzati come utilizzo il
mio diario che tengono il comodino ma ci
relazioniamo con gli altri e soprattutto
bisogna conquistarsi l'autorevolezza
della propria voce
bisogna aggiornarsi bisogna capire che
vi sono novità che ogni giorno vanno
fuori alla velocità della luce bisogna
utilizzarli con una strategia solida ma
flessibile avere degli obiettivi ben
chiari dove vogliamo andare
qual è il mio obiettivo a livello
personale o aziendale che voglio
raggiungere sui suoi social e quindi da
questo punto di vista la meritocrazia un
concetto importante che rende la
democrazia effettiva e non potenziale
perché se non la mia voce una voce tra
milioni di voci
tornando al all'ambito di cui io sono
diciamo così osservatore privilegiato
cioè l'ambito sportivo gli sport
olimpici oggi hanno una grandissima
opportunità e voglio ancora parlare ea
sottolineare questo concetto che quello
che poi può riguardare anche le piccole
e medie imprese cioè con un budget
ridotto accedere a un media pensiamo al
momento storico che viviamo totale
assenza ormai di contributi pubblici
soprattutto allo sport o anche le
risorse dei privati la crisi economica
porta ai privati a non essere più
mecenati le risorse non vengono regalate
nessuno più investe senza la certezza di
un
di un ritorno sull'investimento e quindi
in questo scenario avere dei contenitori
dove raccontare le proprie storie le sue
sportive quindi non parlo solo della
scherma nel mio caso ma in generale di
tutti gli sport cosiddetti minori ha
torto perché l'italia in questo momento
vive anche un momento di crisi culturale
su questo fronte c'è il calcio e poi gli
sport diversi dal calcio
chiusa parentesi è una grande
opportunità
io nel mio piccolo vi racconto cosa
abbiamo fatto dal 2008
siamo stati una delle prime federazioni
esordire sui social abbiamo sviluppato
un format una strategia d visual
storytelling quindi raccontiamo per
immagini che arrivano immediate al cuore
della gente con poche parole poi di
accompagnamento al post raccontiamo
quindi non soltanto quelle che sono le
l'aspetto agonistico le vittorie
successi ma come detto prima il lato
bruce wayne le storie il backstage che
quello che oggi aggancio allo spettatore
e che sta funzionando
vi faccio alcuni esempi delle
opportunità che gli si sono parati uno
degli obiettivi erano era quello di
svecchiare il brand un brand percepito
come austero movimento autoreferenziale
troppo serio e questa è una delle
opportunità che abbiamo colto questa
immagine che vedete bambini di 10 anni
parliamo di un campionato italiano under
abbiamo fatto questi bambini uno scherzo
orrendo abbiamo messo accanto a loro
questo gigante che poi nella vita reale
un ex giocatore di pallacanestro 2 m 17
d'altezza che abbiamo fatto credere che
fosse un bambino di 10 anni con dei
problemi di gigantismo quindi potete
immaginare quanti contenuti virali sono
venuti fuori da questa candid camera
oltre che ovviamente avere traumatizzato
questi bambini i valori una delle leve
più importanti per uno sport olimpico
per uno sport come la scherma è
l'aspetto valoriale non viviamo solo un
momento di crisi economica ma anche di
crisi valoriale bene questa fotografia
me la faccio arrivare diretta al cuore è
un potentissimo spot del nostro sport
campionato italiano under 14 bambini di
12 anni finale che vale il titolo
tricolore uno vince l'altro perde il
match finisce con questo bellissimo
abbraccio che
diciamo c'è tutto dentro c'è l'amicizia
celsa per vincere il saper perdere il
rispetto dell'avversario delle regole il
rispetto dell'arbitro il rispetto del
pubblico tutta una serie di valori
potentissimi che rendono questa
fotografia una delle più cliccate di
quelle che abbiamo proposto in termini
di di post come detto riguarda la
scherma per la prima volta magari non
capisce che cosa accade in pedana però
coglie subito tre elementi che sono
parte del dna di questo sport l'eleganza
la spettacolarità e la dinamicità questi
sono combattimenti volanti tipo tipo
matrix appunto e rendere questo tipo di
immagini significa volere appunto come
ho detto prima alzare il volume a uno
dei nostri punti di forza è abbassare il
volume al punto di debolezza delle
regole complesse
quindi vi do una dimostrazione concreta
il backstage quello che accade dopo la
festa prima si spegneranno i riflettori
suonava l'inno di mameli non si sapeva
più che fine facevano questi ragazzi
fino a un l'anno successivo adesso
invece riusciamo a raccontare ad esempio
la festa per in hotel
la sera dopo la conquista di un titolo
mondiale un titolo europeo sono dei
contenuti validissimi che nella nostra
piattaforma funzionano molto ed è un
modo di invitare la community essere
parte a condividere questa gioia questo
momento e questo poi scaturisce un altro
elemento la fidelizzazione e poi la
possibilità di lanciare delle idee di
promozione della scherma che fanno il
giro del mondo in 24 ore questa è
un'idea che ho avuto nel luglio del 2014
e che vi racconto brevemente si chiama
fencing mob fencing la parola scherma
tradotta in inglese e mob da flash mob
semplicemente ho chiesto tramite un
appunto un evento creato su facebook ho
chiesto ai club di scherma di tutto il
mondo di organizzare ognuno nella
propria città un flash mob di scherma
per celebrare l'inizio della stagione
agonistica 2014 2015 tutti lo stesso
giorno domenica 7 settembre
non ho dato regole particolari non ho
ho dato indicazioni in merito alla
musica al numero dei partecipanti alla
coreografia assoluta libertà l'unica
regola è quella di organizzare questo
flash mob davanti una location
caratterizzante il la città in cui si
svolge quindi a roma il colosseo a
milano il duomo times square a new york
per intenderci e ho creato una mail
dedicata dove in tempo reale ho ricevuto
foto e video da parte degli
organizzatori e in tempo reale gli
opposti nella piattaforma
questa è l'immagine del flash mob di
milano vi dico subito i risultati della
prima edizione 120 le città nel mondo
che hanno partecipato da 25 paesi
diversi
quasi un milione di contatti in 24 ore
sulla piattaforma 8 mila i partecipanti
scesi in strada a costo zero
dell'operazione un post lanciato su
facebook domanda quanto avrei dovuto
pagare se avessi voluto raggiungere quel
numero di contatti nel mondo magari
anche affidandomi a un'agenzia una web
agency
chiusa parentesi quindi la possibilità
di connettersi con il mondo
visto il successo della prima edizione a
gran voce si è invocata la seconda
edizione 6 settembre 2015 seconda
edizione del fancy mob qualcuno era
scettico
magari
adesso manca l'entusiasmo iniziale i
numeri diminuiranno invece no per
fortuna vi dico queste hong kong 181 le
città alla seconda edizione con da 38
paesi diversi
più di un milione e mezzo di contatti
sulla piattaforma in 24 ore e 12 mila
partecipanti minimo comune denominatore
il costo zero dell'operazione è tra
l'altro una elevatissima visibilità sui
media tradizionali ne hanno parlato un
po tutti sia in italia che negli altri
paesi esteri dove si sono organizzati
dove si sono svolte vi faccio qualche
esempio faccio vedere che abbiamo avuto
il flash mob di scherma più alto del
mondo sulle dolomiti ha 3000 m nella
terrazza pordoi
ovviamente è un flash mob non usuale
perché non c'è nessuno a guardare ma
questi simpatici matti che sono saliti a
3000 metri per fare questa foto erano
consci della viralità del contenuto
infatti è stata una delle foto più viste
della prima edizione centro storico di
budapest invaso da 450 da 450
schermitori rendono budapest e la città
col più alto numero di partecipanti
poi abbiamo avuto il fancy in mob con
tre partecipanti più a sud del mondo qui
siamo a ushuaia nella terra del fuoco in
argentina dove finisce il mondo e il più
a nord in islanda a reykjavik
io concludo dicendo che tutto questo
sarebbe appunto mera retorica filosofia
se non vi fossero i numeri la sostanza
ad accompagnare chi viene a vedere un
evento di scherma al massimo sono 23
mila persone sono numeri che io da un
punto di vista dell'appeal commerciale
non posso utilizzare quello che abbiamo
creato è una piattaforma che mi dà la
possibilità di avere 350 400mila
contatti a settimana con picchi di 3
milioni e di capire e di cavalcare
l'onda di un nuovo mercato della
sponsorizzazione che non è più un logo
su un back troppo su un campo gara ma è
l'insieme di inserimento del brand nella
storia nello storytelling come accade
nei film
abbiamo i prodotti placement dove i
brand pagano per essere inseriti nella
storia del film è quello che oggi il
mercato della sponsorizzazione richiede
e come si è evoluto in questo devo dire
con orgoglio siamo stati precursori
io ho concluso e vi ringrazio
[Applauso]